[Music]
oh my god yes sorry I'm sorry
yeah that's adorable oh my god that's so
cute yeah I'll poop here how do you know
him I don't know we have to figure that
out
oh okay let's catch him butterflies you
hate butterflies right don't worry God
why am you caught a ladybug
do I like ladybugs yay no no ohh okay
again finally you're doing something
useful for the thing okay I'm sorry I'm
sorry
oh yeah I am bad boyfriend I'm sorry
your shitty girlfriend you know I just
stop showing your nips please okay thank
you
what are you doing what are you doing
right now
I what are you doing oh my god you did
so well Marta thank you so much for
playing with me today for the thumbnail
we do a little kiss
[Music]